I'm what  up above Lupo come on we didn't even  check your homework folder this weekend  only sweetheart you have a science  project due today why didn't you tell me  that how are we supposed to get this  Donna MA  oh my god this is not that bad  sweetheart I'll give you a dollar if you  find mommy's sunglasses sweetheart I'm  gonna pack you some leftovers really  yummy leftovers okay oh hey honey  does mold count as a science experiment  this their science project  all right got your backpack first on all  right sweetheart get your shoes on I'm  gonna load the car we're getting  Starbucks for breakfast yeah whoo mommy  gets her coffee hurry up with those  shoes we're late just kidding just  kidding mommy forgot her pants nice  outfit oh thanks Tara nice facelift